breaking news al franken senator from
Minnesota is out yes out he just
resigned on the floor of the Senate will
talk all about it plus the media do
their best to ensure that a wave of
terrorism hits Israel and of course
President Trump stands tall in the face
of withering attack over his talk about
Jerusalem I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
Ben Shapiro show
all righty so a lot to get through today
right now in breaking news Al Franken is
stepping down from the Senate when I say
now I mean like as we are recording this
we're gonna grab the audio as soon as
possible of Al Franken the senator from
Minnesota stepping down he did what
I think everyone sort of expected him to
do he came out and he said that he was
totally innocent but he's stepping down
anyway which is not true he's not
totally innocent and also he then said
and what about Trump and what about Roy
Moore this is the Democrats play we'll
talk all about that plus I want to give
you the latest from the State of Israel
as well as a couple of stories that are
just insane that you haven't heard yet
today before I go any further though I
want to say thank you to my sponsors
over at ProFlowers so you know holiday
season is coming up and there are people
that you won't get to see this holiday
season well sending a greeting card n
gonna do it you need to send them
flowers because it's your mom man okay
it's your it's your wife you're gonna be
out of town you need to send flowers
this is what I by the way every time I
go out of town for any extended period
of time I go over to my friends at
ProFlowers and I use them as you send
flowers to my wife it always gives me
good it gets me in good with the missus
right now they have best-selling candy
cane roses a great option for a holiday
gift or you can always go through mini
classic Christmas tree that comes with
lights and ornaments no matter what you
choose my listeners get 20% off any
ProFlowers bouquet or plans of twenty
nine dollars or more they are fantastic
I mean they last longer than they would
if you got them at the store when they
are guaranteed to stay fresh they
arrived in a box to your house if
something is broken and it'll
immediately fix it that's happened to us
and they fixed it immediately you
control the delivery date they give you
more bloom for your about big beautiful
flowers more stems for money long
lasting freshness the quality of the
flowers really is top-notch and again
the delivery is impeccable I mean it
comes with the base if you order it that
way it's just it's just great so you get
20% off all bouquets of $29 and more
this holiday season go to proflowers.com
use my code Ben show at checkout that's
promo code Ben show at checkout and you
get 20% off all bouquets or plans of
twenty nine bucks or more this holiday
season proflowers.com
use that promo code Ben show at checkout
proflowers.com promo code Ben show you
make your spouse happy make your mom
happy make your dad happy it's just it's
it's a happiness company that's what
they do proflowers.com use promo code
Ben show get 20% off any bouquet of
twenty nine dollars or more or any plans
of twenty nine dollars or more check
them out they're awesome proflowers.com
again
that promo code is been show speaking of
people who could use a little bit of
career insurance Al Franken is gone and
he just came out and said as I said that
he is innocent that he didn't do any of
these things that all of these women are
either liars or misconstruing his
actions it seems to me it's hard to
misconstrue somebody grabbing your in
the middle of a photo line but you know
to each his own
so Franken stepped down after the
Democrats turned on him they turn on him
in the last 48 hours really not because
of the new reports about Franken but
because they wish to throw Republicans
under the Moral under the morale bus
that was the goal here the pretext they
used for throwing Franken out was this
was this report from the Atlantic that
said that Franken had sexually harassed
a woman at a Media Matters party there's
a woman named Tina deploy who wrote for
the Atlantic she says it happened in a
media matters party during the first
Obama inauguration it was a great time
to be a Democrat not only had we just
elected the first african-american
president of the United States but
frankenz race had triggered a recount
leaving leftist skiddy we would soon
have a supermajority in the Senate as
you recall Al Franken stole that
Tennessee from Norm Coleman they just
kept recounting the votes until enough
felons were counted that Al Franken was
the senator from Minnesota this woman
writes this is my first inauguration
I've never been in the proverbial room
where it happens my experience with
government at that point was being a
ward of the court in foster care nothing
that I had an interest in politics in
politics and in grandstanding my foster
dad set up an internship for me at the
district office of Representative George
Miller the summer before my senior year
of high school as an intern I answered
calls thumb through the congressional
record etc she does I've been married
for two years at the time I don't let my
husband touch me like Al Franken did in
public right here's what she says
I saw Al Franken I only bug celebrities
for pictures when it'll make my foster
mom happy she loves Franken so I asked
to get a picture with him he posted the
shot he immediately put his hand on my
waist grabbing a handful of flesh I
froze then he squeezed at least twice
what a class act that Al Franken so
Franken gave a statement which he said
all of this has been misconstrued he's
totally innocent but he's leaving anyway
and then he blabbered on for a while
about activism and the wonders of
activism and again he just kept calling
them liers over and over and over hoping
that he would have another shot at this
that's what Al Franken is hoping al
franken is hoping that he leaves in
quote-unquote disgrace that he does his
penance and then he comes back in a
couple of years having cleansed himself
of the stigma
this in order to ensure that he
immediately wheeled and hit Trump and
and Roy Moore Roy Moore of course the
Senate Alabama Republican candidate
who's been credibly accused of child
molestation
now what's hilarious about all of this
is watching the Democrats swing to push
Franken out so just a couple of days ago
we played the audio yesterday of kirsten
gillibrand saying that she didn't know
whether Franken should step down he
should really make his own decision and
then yesterday she actually said Franken
should step down so if she changed her
opinion kirsten gillibrand who's been
treated as a possible 2020 candidate
there is no better weather vane than
kirsten gillibrand I mean there are no
better weather vanes on planet earth
than Kirsten Gillibrand the woman has
her finger in the air at all times seen
which way the wind is blowing she
realized that she wanted the way she
realized the limb is blowing against
Franken so she stepped out in front of
that and said Franken should resign is
what she said yesterday
well obviously there were new
allegations today and enough is enough I
mean this is a conversation we've been
having for a very long time and it's a
conversation that this country needs to
have and I think when we start having to
talk about the differences between
sexual assault and sexual harassment and
unwanted groping you are having the
wrong conversation you need to draw a
line in the sand and say none of it is
OK
none of it is acceptable and we as
elected leaders should absolutely be
held to a higher standard
not a lower standard that's a wild
switch from Kirsten Gillibrand who five
seconds ago was saying that basically Al
Franken might stay but Roy Moore should
go and president Trump's a sexual abuser
but not Al Franken this is all this is
all a wild shift I will say that the
logic that's used here that we have to
lump all of this activity together is a
little bit disturbing to me I don't
think that Harvey Weinstein should be
lumped together with Al Franken and I
don't think that Al Franken should be
lumped together with like Clarence
Thomas who apparently made a crude
sexual remark to Anita - Anita Hill one
time or was alleged to have done so the
this does not seem to me that all of
these things should be grouped together
or posed equivalent threats to careers
some of these activities are truly
horrifying and your career should be
ended you should end up in jail and some
of these activities are bad you're a
creep but I'm not sure that it rises to
the level of the of the same outrage as
a Harvey Weinstein for example in any
case but this is really about for
Democrats and we all know it what this
is really about is seizing the moral
high ground what Democrats truly want to
do here is not push out Franken because
they care about Franken not push out
John Conyers because they care about
John Conyers
they want to push all these people out
so that they can turn and swivel and hit
Donald Trump and Roy more so senator
mazie Hirono the Democrat of Hawaii she
came out yesterday and she said you know
now that Franken is going you know be
really great as if Trump and more
stepped aside and they say what Al
Franken did was wrong but it's not even
in the same ballpark why take this step
and why not also be calling for
president Trump and and Roy Moore to
step aside well I would love it if both
of them stepped aside because I've said
publicly that the president Trump has
admitted to being a sexual predator and
as for Roy Moore the credible
allegations of him being a child
molester basically they should cause
both of them to look at themselves and
step down I would love it but at the
same time you know I'm looking for where
the Republican voices where is their
outrage in fact on the opposite end
they're coming forward to support one
more
how's that for totally inappropriate
position so two things can be true once
one Democrats can be right to shove
these people out the door and
Republicans should do the same with
their own bad candidates and two this
can be totally politically driven
because it is totally politically driven
I mean there's no question about it the
fact is that the Democrats suffer zero
repercussions for getting rid of Franken
the Democratic governor of Minnesota
Mark Dayton is about to appoint his
lieutenant governor I can't her name
escapes me for the moment but he's about
to appoint her a Democrat she filled
Franken seats the Democrats don't lose a
seat in the Senate forcing out John
Conyers means nothing because some
relative of John Conyers will fill that
seat it's very easy to take the moral
high ground when it doesn't mean
actually sacrificing anything anytime
Democrats have to think about
sacrificing something they rally around
the flag of the sexual abuser the same
way that Republicans are currently
rallying around the flags of alleged
sexual abusers so there's no question
that there's a bunch of hypocrisy going
on here and a bunch of political
posturing Bernie Sanders another example
he came out yesterday or this morning
rather and he said that Donald Trump and
Roy Moore should both step down because
Al Franken is going earlier this week
Bernie Sanders is literally running away
from the cameras when he was asked about
Al Franken so what's happened here is
that the Democrats waited until the
Republican National Committee and Trump
Rhee endorsed more and they said here's
our chance to draw a contrast now is
that smart politics of course it's smart
politics now they get to claim that they
have the moral high ground and
Republicans meanwhile are shoving the
moral high ground away from them
as fast as humanly possible I mean
they're taking that moral high ground
and they are running from it as fast as
humanly possible so much so they are
actually seeing Republicans now come out
and start to defend Al Franken till last
night on Laura Ingraham John Fox News
Newt Gingrich was talking with Ingram
and both Gingrich and Ingram were
actually defending Al Franken because
they understand what's happening next
right here here's the logic well we're
not gonna let Trump and more go until
you get rid of Al Franken Democrats say
fine we'll get rid of Al Franken then
the repose it will hold on hold up a
second
maybe you don't want to get rid of Al
Franken may that's a bad idea to get rid
of Al Franken it's all political
partisanship at its finest here's
Gingrich with Ingram suddenly defending
al Frank and a guy who routinely grabs
women by the butt in the middle of photo
lines apparently al franken was a
comedian
comedians often do weird things he was
in the entertainment business he was
doing the kind of things people in the
entertainment business do now I have not
maybe I'm wrong but I don't see anything
that they've said he's done since he was
a senator I don't think they said tried
to lose track I think there are a couple
allegations of inappropriate conduct
I think it's minor so yeah but the point
is we are wearing one of those weird
American moments when running around
lynching people seals if you go back
anyway you go back and watch the YouTube
of Clarence Thomas a was wonderful and
sworn in Kalista oh great great moment
and you know fellow Georgia and
everything you go back and you look at
what he said about an electronic
lynching and then you look at what we're
saying we had a lot of good reasons to
retire but on the other hand no hearings
no you're accused and you're a man
you're a so here we are now right so
here we got we've got Laura Ingraham and
Newt Gingrich defending Al Franken you
think they're doing that because they
really like Al Franken or they think Al
Franken ought to get a fair shake I mean
they're both calling for the prosecution
of Hillary Clinton based on less
evidence than Al Franken here Hillary
Clinton by the way should have gone to
jail okay the idea that they are out
defending Al Franken today the only
reason they're defending Al Franken is
because they want to defend Roy Moore
obviously that's what's going on here in
the demo
rats are only throwing out Franken under
the bus because they want to get ROI
morons ahnold's rum so understand this
is all a political game don't suddenly
think that politicians grew moral spines
they didn't okay I would be happy if
they had and maybe we can force them
into doing so but I don't really see the
purpose of pretending that there's no
politics at work here at all because
that's just that's just silly
well in a second I want to play you what
Al Franken actually had to say but first
I want to say thank you to our sponsors
over at Birch gold so with the
increasing uncertainty of the upcoming
of the of the upcoming events with with
disaster in the air it seems on the
foreign front with what I did in North
Korea with the fact that the stock
market is is it all-time highs you can
expect it to readjust at some point in
the future that's why you should at
least be hedging your bets with some
precious metals and that's what Birch
gold is there for Birch gold group has a
long-standing track record of continued
success thousands of satisfied clients
countless five-star reviews an A+ rating
with the Better Business Bureau you can
contact Birch gold group right now to
request a free information kit on
physical precious metals the
comprehensive 16 page kit reveals how
gold and silver can protect your savings
they can legally move your IRA or 401k
out of risky stocks and bonds and into a
precious metals IRA to get that no-cost
no-obligation kit go to birchgold.com
slash Bend that's birchgold.com slash
been ask all your questions get all your
information and then when you're ready
invest in precious metals it's good to
hedge your bets it's just worthwhile to
have some of your portfolio in gold I
certainly do and talk to my friends over
at Birch gold group they are trustworthy
folks and you can see I did an interview
with them that you can view online as
well okay so we do finally have tape of
Al Franken the fact that Democrats
thought this guy was a viable 2020
contender tells you everything you need
to know about the state of the
Democratic Party but here is al franken
on the floor of the Senate resigning but
not before claiming that he's innocent
and that he'd be murdered nevertheless
today I am announcing that in the coming
weeks I will be resigning as a member of
the United States Senate I of all people
am aware that there is some irony in the
fact that I am leaving while a man who
is bragged on tape about his history of
sexual assault sits in the Oval Office
and a man who has repeatedly preyed on
young
girl's campaigns for the Senate with
with the full support of his party yeah
and so that's the that's the line the
Democrats are going to use so when you
say this isn't political of course it's
political now Franken were smart if he
had any sense of the moment what he
would do instead is hew to a full mayor
call Paul right he'd get up there and
instead of denying that the accuser
instead of saying the accusers are a
bunch of terrible people who are lying
about him and that he's a wounded
innocent he and he then went on to say
I'll be fine you know I was comedian
before this I'll be fine everything will
be fine what he should have done if he
were smart is he would have said all of
these women I believe them women deserve
to be believed I've made a lot of
mistakes I apologized fulsomely for the
mistakes that I've made and in this new
America I hope to change for the better
and President Trump is evidence that the
Republicans are not changing for the
better if I have to step down as I
should then I call on President Trump to
step down as well right he should have
actually turned it into a rallying cry
but he's not smart enough to do that he
doesn't have the wherewithal to do that
if he'd done that the media would have
actually orgasmed like people actually
would have would have experienced
physical pleasure and at that point he
could have run for president in 2020 but
he doesn't have the brains to do that as
I say the Republicans meanwhile are
rushing to defend Roy Moore and this is
something that I think is is both stupid
and backwards so they're a bunch of
people saying well you know the
Democrats are only doing this for
political reasons so why should we came
and there is this mentality on the right
now that when the Democrats will want
something you don't give it to them just
because they just because they want it
right but that's not the case with Roy
Moore okay there's this there's this new
mentality that I think has has taken
hold among a lot of Republicans among
some conservatives that just because the
Democrats don't want something they or
just because the Democrats want
something you can't give it to them that
the Democrats because their political
everything that they say is false
that's not right and it also leads you
down a pretty dark road and I think that
you know Steve Bannon is sort of the
avatar of this I think Steve Bannon
really helps make this sort of mentality
come to fruition right aux a little bit
about him yesterday with regard to what
he was saying about Roy Moore and
turning on Mitt Romney and it is
indicative of how a lot of Republicans
are thinking right now which is that Roy
Moore must be innocent because the
Democrats say he's guilty that Roy Moore
must be defended
the Democrats wants him out I don't see
why you would surrender the moral
high-ground this way on a race that
Republicans you know if they had thrown
more out earlier or more resigned they
would have won this race walking away
even if Roy Jones Doug Jones the
Democrat were to win this seat
Republicans would be able to regain the
seat in four years when it comes up
again it's a heavily red state but
instead the Republicans seem to be
pushing the high ground away with both
hands saying listen the Democrats got to
play in the muck for a while now we're
gonna play in the muck they don't
understand there's a different standard
that applies to Republicans there is as
there should be because Republican not
not that there should be a different
standard for Republicans but the higher
standard should apply to both
Republicans and Democrats and I don't
see the Republicans recognizing that
baseline reality it is a baseline
reality by the way that that that is the
case you see that but with the doubt
with the Republicans attacking Mitt
Romney right Stephan Bannon yesterday
attacking Mitt Romney and I just thought
to myself there is a strain of the
Republican Party that now says the worst
the person the more we ought to support
them and I think that's true among
Democrats when it's politically
beneficial for that to be the case I
think they'll get there too and they'll
use the polarization in politics has an
excuse to get there and Republicans
aren't wrong that a lot rides on
politics that a lot is at stake but they
are wrong when they think that the way
that they are going to win is by is by
embracing the worst elements of their of
their own of their own egos and their
own id's
I just think that's that's a huge
mistake now with all that said I
understand why the frustrate frustration
among the Republicans why there's so
much frustration that the Democrats been
getting away with this stuff for 20
years and not just on the sexual-assault
front but on the corruption front this
is a story that sort of went unmentioned
but it's amazing the New York Times has
a report on the operation of the
consumer protection financial Bureau
under the command of interim director
Mick Mulvaney and in the article is a
real piece of news that a group of
bureaucrats have decided to hijack the
CFPB as much as possible and operate in
secret to define Mulvaney this according
to hot air comm here's what they
actually said agency employees said they
were scrutinizing every comment and memo
from their new leader for hints about
their future some employees including a
few of the bureau's top officials have
welcomed their new leader others
pointing to mr. Mulvaney's earlier
hostility toward the agency and his
mission are quietly resisting one small
group calls itself
Dumbledore's Army according to two of
the people who are familiar
their discussions the name is a
reference to a secret resistance force
in the Harry Potter books and atmosphere
of intense anxiety has taken hold
several employee said so um first of all
read another book not every reference
has to be about Harry Potter but second
of all there's an actual band of
bureaucrats inside the CFPB trying to
buck Trump and call himself Dumbledore's
Army then you wonder why Republicans are
so frustrated they say that they say we
need someone who's willing to break the
rules to stop a bunch of people who are
willing to break the rules
the frustration with partisan politics
has driven both sides mad and if the
standard can only be restored through
hypocrisy then better that the standards
should be restored through the hypocrisy
of going after Al Franken in order to
get to Roy more than that the standard
never be restored at all okay so in
other news there's a lot of fallout over
what's happening in Jerusalem right now
so the President of the United States
yesterday made the announcement that
Jerusalem was in fact to be recognized
as the capital of Israel by the American
government
and that he'll be working to move the
embassy from Tel Aviv to Jerusalem which
makes perfect sense Jerusalem is the
eternal capital of the Jewish people
always was the capital of Israel always
will be the capital of Israel here is
president Trump announcing that
yesterday after more than two decades of
waivers we are no closer to a lasting
peace agreement between Israel and the
Palestinians it would be folly to assume
that repeating the exact same formula
would now produce a different or better
result therefore I have determined that
it is time to officially recognize
Jerusalem as the capital of Israel while
previous presidents have made this a
major campaign promise they failed to
deliver today I am delivering I've
judged this course of action to be in
the best interests of the United States
of America and the pursuit of peace
between Israel and the Palestinians full
marks for this I mean this is it this is
a brave move by the President of the
United States and of course the media
because they foster terrorism and they
don't mind terrorism and they were fine
with the Gaza war and they're rooting
for Hamas many of them now they're
turning on
Trump and say well it's because of this
that there will be violence in the
Middle East you're right the terrorist
group Hamas which is a terrorist group
there was a really angry only over
Jerusalem then they declared a three
days of Rage I love this the media oh my
god
days of Rage from the Palestinians days
of Rage man they wouldn't be enraged
except for Trump this is the fourth time
the Palestinians fourth have declared a
day of rage in the last eight months
okay since April they've declared four
days of Rage this is the last day like
ever is it ad anding enlighten today of
Rage in the West Bank and Gaza Strip in
Judea and Samaria and Gaza right the
Palestinians are constantly pushing days
of Rage why because the leadership is
corrupt because the leadership are a
bunch of terrorists because the
population voted for that leadership and
because the leadership knows that if
they attack Israel they don't actually
have to provide anything to their own
citizens and so the media coverage which
is treating this is like it's panic time
it's the end of the world it's all
because of sure it's all because of
Trump it's just a nonsense
okay Hamas 1988 is their covenant this
is their founding document quote Israel
Judaism and Jews challenge Islam and the
people may the cowards never
sleep PLO charters the Palestinian
Authority right is Mahmoud Abbas is
group quote the establishment of Israel
is illegal and null and void that was in
1964 before Israel even controlled the
Old City of Jerusalem before they even
controlled East Jerusalem and they were
calling for the destruction of Israel
but know something something is
definitely changed Abbas by the way made
a speech yesterday where he quote noted
long Christian and Muslim history in
Jerusalem makes no mention of Jewish
history their quote it's an attempt to
change our history and it will not
succeed
it's a Palestinian city in Arab City a
Christian city and a Muslim city okay so
it's not the Jews not recognizing that
Islam and that the Muslims have
connections to to Jerusalem worth the I
mean it's the Jews we Jews and Israelis
in particular who have acknowledged that
holy sites should remain open but the
fact that yet but but the fact that the
Muslim population over there doesn't
want Jewish sites to remain open that as
I talked about yesterday
when the Muslims controlled Jerusalem
they refused to allow access to holy
sites to Jews and actually started riot
if Jews brought so much as a folding
chair for the ill and the infirm to pray
at the western wall you know and now the
media is blaming Trump for acknowledging
a reality it's just insipid and because
of that
because of that you're gonna get more
terrorism because the the terrorists
know it's funny the same people who will
say let's not name mass shooters we
can't name mass shooters if we name mass
shooters it's glorifying the mass
shootings there's some merit to that the
idea that they are going to go out there
and go out in the middle of the Gaza
Strip or Judea and Samaria and put a
camera on a bunch of people burning
stuff and treat this as though it's
Trump's fault all that's doing is
fostering terrorism they're gonna get
people killed the media's and the
media's attempts to create a massive
conflagration out of this it's just
going to encourage terrorists to be
terrorists this is what the media do its
roots really despicable and this has
some far ranging ramifications outside
of Israel by the way we'll talk about
those plus BB Netanyahu's response in
just a second first I want to say thank
you to our sponsors over at filter by
comm so right now in California we are
experiencing wildfire season when I say
we're experienced in wildfire season I
mean it was smoky in the office
yesterday I mean there was a giant there
was a giant wildfire not 15 minutes from
here and there was another giant
wildfire not 20 minutes from my house I
mean it was it just the wildfires are
raging out of control here in California
it means there's a lot of ash and dust
in the air well now would be a good time
for you to replace the filters in your
house folks the fact is that you
probably haven't thought about replacing
the air filters in your house because
that's not something you think about
until three years to lay open it up and
there's black mold in there that's why
you need to go to filter by dot-com
right now and get the best price on top
quality air filter shipped within 24
hours Plus free shipping filter by
dot-com as filter buys outcome we spend
90% of our time indoors
and according to studies the air at your
family brief contains up to a hundred
times greater air pollution than the air
outside which is one of the reasons why
you need good air filters filter buys
outcome sends you the size you need
within 24 hours plus free shipping plus
you can even get on a schedule so they
send you all of the new filters as they
as they come up so you're changing your
HVAC filter regularly you can set it and
forget it at filter buy.com and again
you save 5% when you sign up for auto
delivery so go to filter by com sign up
for the auto delivery and then you won't
ever have to worry about when you check
your filters again when they arrive you
replace them it's that simple just like
you're replacing your toothbrush head or
just like you'd be replacing any other
regular product that arrives at your
door you're replacing your air filters
it's a great idea and you should engage
filter buy.com today make sure that you
get the best price on top quality
filters and sign up for
regular refresh so the day is that you
get 5% off as well filter by dot-com
check it out okay so Bibi Netanyahu
thanks president Trump for what Trump
did yesterday as well he should here was
Netanyahu yesterday the president's
decision is an important step towards
peace for there is no peace
that doesn't include Jerusalem as the
capital of the State of Israel
president Trump thank you for today's
historic decision to recognize Jerusalem
as Israel's capital the Jewish people
and the Jewish state will be forever
grateful okay and that's exactly right I
was talking to some people who are in
Jerusalem yesterday they were ecstatic
as well they should be and again this is
just a recognition of reality it's not
that something fundamentally has changed
if you aren't gonna recognize the
reality of how the world works you're
never gonna be able to achieve peace the
media don't want to accept this no the
media are trying to treat this as though
this was some sort of crazy move by
Trump cuz Trump's a crazy man and
Trump's gonna set the world afire let's
be really clear about one thing one of
the things that's really ironic here Cid
Arabia doesn't give a crap about
Jerusalem the Jordanians don't give a
crap about Jerusalem the Egyptians don't
give a crap about your Islam they're not
gonna back any Palestinian uprising
against the Israelis you know why
because of Barack Obama
not because of Trump because of Barack
Obama because Barack Obama made Iran a
regional power and now Saudi Arabia
Jordan and Egypt they're all siding with
Israel and attempt to create a coalition
to check Iranian growth in the region so
the Palestinians are on their own so if
you're lamenting the poor Palestinians
being on their own against the big bad
Israelis talk to President Obama not
President Trump because the fact is that
coalition only exists on the back of
President Obama's decision to make Iran
a regional power pretty incredible stuff
but again the media are stirring this
stuff they're stirring the pot they did
it during the Gaza war I went on CNN I
said that if Hamas could have created a
news network it would look a lot like
CNN but you go back and look at the tape
and the reason I said that is because
CNN always covers these these
conflagrations not as a bunch of
terrorists who've decided to murder Jews
and it as an excuse for media attention
and an attempt to pressure Israel but
they treat it as a spontaneous outburst
thing of rage it's not spontaneous folks
nothing happened yesterday that means
it's an organized effort okay apparently
there's basic lockdown in the city of
Jerusalem right now Jews
told to stay home stay indoors not take
public transportation because of the
fears of terrorism again the Israelis
been pressured into many concessions
including the full withdrawal of Jews
from the Gaza Strip making it completely
you'd and ride they pulled out six
thousand Jews from their homes in the
Gaza Strip there was not one riot there
was not one killing from the Jews
Jerusalem has just declared the capital
of Israel by the United States it has
been forever the capital of Israel and
the Palestinians are using that as an
excuse to ride but again it's just an
excuse they rioted earlier this year
when three Palestinians stabbed someone
to death and tried to shoot some people
up on the Temple Mount and the Israelis
installed metal detectors there were
riots in Jerusalem over metal detectors
so as I say basically damning and why
Palestinians are gonna riot and the
media is gonna treat it as though they
have a legit excuse to do so because
they really despise the Israelis and
they despise the Israeli government led
by Bibi Netanyahu Chris Matthews is one
element of this so here's Chris Matthews
all right happens at least a show
another thing about Ezra done nothing
about Christians but you know the reason
Trump did this is because Jesus that's
why I could because of Jesus go and a
couple more points in our bama
don't think this is a related to Alabama
next week it is related because it's the
Christian evangelicals down there with
their crazy ideas about Israel which is
I don't know mythical they don't
understand the situation over there and
how tricky it is ethnically and tribally
they don't care because it's a religious
belief
Trump's plane to that this week you
watch them okay so it's all about the
crazy evangelicals their crazy beliefs
you mean the crazy judeo-christian
beliefs that undergird all of Western
civilization would that be those beliefs
or is he talking about this myth that
all evangelical Christians wants all the
Jews to go back to Israel so that
Armageddon will come and Jesus will
return because that's a very small
minority of evangelical Christians I
spent a lot more time with un Jellicle
Christians than Chris Matthews has and
he is just ignorant he's just ignorant I
talk with evangelical Christians all the
time the reason they support Israel is
because they believe that they are the
branch of which Israel is the route that
Israel is the route the people of Israel
were the route God's promised to Israel
is the route of the and they are the
branch from the same tree and they
believe that the Jews are God's chosen
people and they don't just believe that
because they want Armageddon to come
that's a tiny minority of evangelical
Christians like when I say Tonya I mean
minut infinitesimal if you want to see
the level of support for Israel from
people like Pastor John Hagee for
example and Kufa
the Christians United for Israel they're
not doing that because they think that
Jesus gonna come back and they're gonna
get raptured up to heaven and that's why
they're doing this
Chris Mathis has to slander all of the
people who support Israel among the
Christians in in the United States
because the left really despises real
this is one area where it's it's become
increasingly partisan and it's really
sad the fact is that 90 nothing 19 even
but like dianne feinstein come out and
say it's just terrible the Trump did
this 90 nothing including Dianne
Feinstein's vote they voted in June to
say that Jerusalem was the undivided
capital of Israel after they voted in
June okay I was like a few months ago
and now they're coming out and saying
it's the end of the world that Trump
announced all this and then of course
you have media flax like Fareed Zakaria
on CNN saying that Trump isn't really
siding with Israel you see when Trump
declares that the Israeli capital
Jerusalem is the Israeli capital
Jerusalem and the eternal capital of the
Jewish people is the eternal capital of
the Jewish people he's not really siding
with Israel he's just siding with
Netanyahu and the Israeli government
Israel doesn't need you know the United
States has an ally anymore in the sense
that they're the most powerful force on
the ground by far Israel is sort of a
regional superpower and compared to the
Palestinians the disproportion is now
just gigantic what they need is for the
United States to have credibility with
the Palestinians so that there can be a
meaningful negotiation if the United
States is seen as blatantly one-sided it
doesn't help and by the way this is an
issue on which the United States would
be citing not with Israel but with the
current Israeli government a this is
absolute sheer unmitigated nonsense the
labor party okay the left of Israeli
politics supports president Trump's
decision on this the left likes
president Trump's decision on this in
Israel when Fareed Zakaria says that we
need that America needs to be seen as an
honest broker in order to broker a peace
that's not true okay the the United
States should be throwing its weight on
the side of the of the people who
actually are in favor of Liberty why
should there be another terrorist state
in the region if there's gonna be peace
the Palestinian Authority has to go
Hamas has to go Islamic Jihad has to go
and what you need instead is something
like a regular liberal government yeah
you can't just say that the United
States should be an honest broker
between al Qaeda and the government of
Pakistan and you can't say that in in a
far worse way you certainly can't say
that the
State should be an honest broker between
Israel and its terrorist enemies it's
just insipid okay so meanwhile in in
other news I want to talk a little bit
about some trends in American thinking
particularly among young people because
this is pretty crazy stuff so there is a
there's a an article today about
capitalism and how young Americans feel
about capitalism from The Wall Street
Journal and it is pretty stunning how
few Americans young Americans
particularly know what capitalism is so
there's an article it says that in a
2016 survey for Harvard University's
Institute of Politics 42% of younger
Americans said they support capitalism
only 19 percent identified themselves as
capitalists is according to john de la
Volpe who's been pulling Millennials for
17 years right 42 percent of young
Americans said they support capitalism
which means 58 percent do not and 19
percent identified themselves as
capitalists the reason that I think this
is the case is because the Democrats and
Bernie Sanders in particular have done a
wonderful job of redefining capitalism
away from its meaning and Republicans
have never discussed capitalism in moral
terms it's something I like talking
about a lot the reason that capitalism
is a good is not just because it's more
efficient and creates better products is
because it says that the stuff that you
create you get to keep the stuff that
you create you get to keep and no one
can be the master of your time or labor
no one gets to enslave you just because
they have needs right you're you this is
the John Locke view of capitalism right
John Locke's view of property ownership
is that you combine your labor with the
land and that's why you have a right to
land the same thing holds true of
capital you combine your labor with
capital you compile you combine your
input with capital your investment
knowledge with capital and now that is
your money and the idea that anyone can
take that money away from you just
because they want the money for their
own purposes is morally obtuse but
people on the right don't talk about
capitalism this way instead what we'll
say is well you know capitalism it's
just sort of the best available system
and there's also this tendency I think
to to say as many have said in the past
that did you know sort of two cheers for
capitalism the capitalism is the best
possible system but it doesn't tell you
that you have to be moral that's true
but when you're talking about economic
socialism doesn't tell you that you have
to be moral either there's nothing moral
about socialism we're talking about
economic systems and why economic
systems ought to be upheld from
oral standpoint you have to start from
the basic notion that human beings have
Liberty that individuals are guaranteed
Liberty and they're all made in God's
image and we are all equal in our rights
before God that does not mean that we
all get to steal stuff from one another
and socialism is immoral capitalism is
moral but young people are never told
that instead what they see is greedy
plutocrats who are combining with the
government and capitalism itself is
slandered in the media so every time
there is a in actual greedy plutocrat it
makes a deal with the government any
time in Wall Street gets rich off an
insider crony zeal of Congress instead
of people responding by saying that's
not capitalism even the right we'll call
it crony capitalism crony capitalism is
not a real term crony capitalism is the
reverse of capitalism it's actually
called corporatism there is no reason to
describe anything as crony capitalism
because capitalism is about the free
investment in exchange of goods but the
right never describes capitalism that
way and so young people don't know any
better and so they ends up in this sort
of weird spot where they think
capitalism is bad but it's not just
ignorance on that there's a Pew poll
that came out yesterday that really is
quite astonishing in in its
ramifications so this is this is what
the poll shows it's assessments on
whether life is better or worse than it
was 50 years ago and it shows what
people think in various countries so the
very bottom of the list of course is
Venezuela where people are eating dogs
but the very top of the list is Vietnam
where they say 88 percent say it's
better than it was 50 years ago that
makes sense in 1967 we're in the middle
of the Vietnam War so things were pretty
bad at that point and the Vietcong took
over and that was pretty bad too Vietnam
has opened up a fair bit since then
India is number two on the list of
places that are better off than they
were 50 years ago these are obviously
countries that understand that that
economic development matters right South
Korea Japan Germany Turkey Turkey's an
interesting one because 50 the I'm not
sure honest to be honest with you where
turkey was 50 years ago but in recent
years they've obviously slid and then
you have the Netherlands Sweden Poland
Spain a lot of countries that are from
the former Soviet bloc so where is the
United States here where is the United
States when it comes to our people
better off or worse off than they were
50 years ago this is an amazing
statistic only 37% of Americans say that
Americans are better off today than they
were 50 years ago 41% of Americans say
that they are worse off than they were
50 years ago 50
years ago in 1967 in the middle of riots
in the United States in the middle of
the Vietnam War with economic
development that you know having a car
was was a having a nice car was still a
luxury you know where you didn't have
the Internet you didn't have the houses
were smaller air conditioning was still
not Universal central air central
heating right there weren't such a thing
as computers the living standard in the
United States is so much higher than it
was in 1967 and yet Americans believe
that this is not the case that they are
they were better off then and this is
one of the problems I think in American
politics right now there's this sort of
nostalgia for a better time there was no
better time I've said this before you
are living in the best time in history
okay this is the better time when people
say do when you wish you had lived right
now you know why because I can connect
with any piece of information on the
planet at any time of night or day hey I
can go to the grocery store and I can
get any delicacy I want from anywhere on
planet Earth I can live in a bigger
house if I can pay for it and I can pay
for it right this is one of the
beautiful things about living in the
United States things have gotten
incredibly better but people refuse to
recognize this and so instead you ends
up with this weird perception that
things have gotten worse and if you
think things have gotten worse you end
up in desperate straits cuz you think
things are constantly getting bad then
every election you're one step from the
end of the country every election is the
end of the road you can't have a
forward-looking view where you say yeah
Obama was garbage who's a bad president
if you're on the right but guess what
the country didn't collapse and that
means that we can actually build a
movement and move the country towards
something even more glorious instead
every election becomes the be-all
end-all you see the same thing from
Democrats where one election from
Armageddon
if you always think in one election from
Armageddon you're actually bringing
Armageddon closer talking about how
Armageddon is right around the corner
makes people act as though Armageddon is
right around the corner and if you act
as the Armageddon is right around the
corner it probably is by the way life
expectancy in the United States in 1967
at points of birth was 71 years today
life expectancy in the United States is
79 years on that basis alone life is
significantly better in the United
States than it was 50 years ago I mean
especially for minorities he kidding me
like black people in 1967 versus black
people in 2017 are you out of your mind
to think that things were better in 1967
literal race riots in Detroit in 1967
hey you really if you were gay in 1967
you better off now or better in 1967 if
you're Jewish hey this is all it's all
it's all nonsense but but unfortunately
we have a tendency to be pessimists
about reality and this leads us some
down some dark roads and toward a
nostalgia on one side that says that we
can rectify everything with big
government and nostalgia on the other
side that says that we have to freeze
everything in place lest lest we fall
into the best okay so I want to get some
things I like and some things I hate but
first you're gonna have to go over to
Daley wire.com for $9.99 a month you two
can get your subscription at Daley
wire.com when you do so then you'll get
the rest of my show live on video you'll
get the rest of me under Clavin show
live on video the rest of Michael
Knowles's show live on video plus you
get to be part of my mailbag which is
happening tomorrow should be an
interesting mail back and our fourth
episode of the conversation is coming up
on Tuesday December 12th at 5 p.m.
Eastern 2 p.m. Pacific
featuring yours truly subscribe today to
be a part of the conversation ask me
which
ask me questions I will either answer or
mock and then answer in the order they
are entered into the live feed my
conversation will stream live on ben
shapiro facebook page daily where a
youtube channel it's free for everybody
to watch only subscribers can ask
questions if you want to ask questions
as a subscriber log in to our website de
wire comm and then head over to the
conversation page to watch the live
stream after that just start typing into
the daily wired chat box I'll answer
questions as they come in for yes one
entire hour once again subscribe to get
your questions answered by yours truly
Ben Shapiro on Tuesday December 12 5
p.m. Eastern 2 p.m. Pacific join the
conversation
if you want the annual subscription at
all of those things plus you get this
the greatest tumbler in all the world
leftist here's hot or cold tumblr you'll
enjoy every second of its ownership and
usage so check that out plus the annual
subscription is cheaper than the monthly
subscriptions so that's good too please
subscribe later if you just want to
listen
it is a subscribe later at YouTube
SoundCloud iTunes leave us a review the
review is always help with the iTunes
ranking so please leave us a review if
you haven't already and and you know we
always appreciate it this is the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast in
the nation
all righty so let's do some things I
like some things I hate and then the big
idea because it's a Thursday can't
believe it's a Thursday already and also
this week has been endless so okay time
for some things that I like so the other
night my wife and I went to see a movie
which was just a pleasure once in a
while I actually get to see my wife and
it's nice when that happens and the
movie was Murder on the Orient Express
so I'm a big alpha a gothic Christie fan
I own all of her novels I knew the
ending my wife didn't so this is one of
those things where it's really fun to
watch if the person you're watching with
does not know the ending to Murder on
the Orient Express because if you don't
know the ending it's one of the great
endings in kind of murder mystery
literature the the middle of the movie
where Poirot is sort of investigating
the crimes is not my favorite the
beginning I think is clever and then you
get to the end and the end is I think
actually quite effective it's based on
Murder on the Orient Express I believe
the book was written 1934 it was
originally based on the Charles
Lindbergh baby kidnapping so if you
don't know about that case Charles
Lindbergh and his wife had a baby the
baby was kidnapped and killed by I
believe a German guy named Bruno
Hauptmann was the guy who was put on
trial for it this book was based on that
and it's not a giveaway to say that the
character who's killed right it's called
Murder on the Orient Express someone has
killed the person who was killed it
turns out was involved in a similar
kidnapping and the whole movie is sort
of about that it's effective
I think Branagh uses some nice touches I
don't want to give spoilers because the
movies still out in theatres but there
are some differences from the books
Poirot himself his whole character is
much more sympathetic in the movie than
he would be in the books and the books
Poirot is basically a machine he used he
uses little gray cells to logically
deduce things but in the movie he has a
lot more sympathy and they sort of give
him not a love interest but they say
that his he's had a wife who died that's
not true in the books in the books he
he'd never had a love interest but the
cast I think a lot of the cast is quite
good
Branagh is fun to watch Michelle
Pfeiffer is actually terrific in it
Johnny Depp is really good I don't like
Johnny Depp as an actor and Johnny Depp
actually is really good in this so check
it out I'm around the orange Express
here's a little bit of preview
would you mind if I join you
good a world-famous detective Hercule
Poirot the bender of the innocent is
that what they told you in the papers
and you are you no sense
a passenger has died he was murdered the
murderer is on the train with us now and
every one of you is a suspect so let us
catch a killer so there there are a few
things in the movie that would have made
it better one is that the murder takes
place on a train on a moving train what
would have been nice in a bunch of
sleeper cars that are bright back to
back it would have been nice to have
like a map of the sleeper car this
appointment by sunny Bunch on the weekly
standard of podcasts and I think it's
right that one shot from above that
shows where everybody was in the cars
would be very helpful but you don't
actually get that but the movie itself
is is worth what particularly the end of
it is is pretty effective I think okay
so time for some other things that I
like so this I thought was just
hilarious
so yesterday or a couple days ago on the
show I said that it was a lifelong dream
to appear on the view and I was very
excited about this Paula Faris who is an
occasional co-host on the view and she's
on Good Morning America she tweeted out
hey Ben I heard on your podcast that
wanted her lifelong dreams to swip here
on the view I'm running it by the
incomparable Joy Behar stay tuned then
she tweeted out a picture of herself
with Joy Behar all I can say is I accept
yes make this happen it would be the
greatest hour of television in the
history of daytime it would be so good I
believe there's a petition online to
petition ABC to have me on it would be a
lot of fun I've made fun of the view at
times but I will but I will I will be
cordial and and in kind so check it out
if they have me on the view it'll be
fantastic I could not be more excited
about this I was dancing around the
office yesterday and May it's hard to
make me happy so Thank You Paula Faris
and I hope that this actually happens
okay time for a couple of things that I
hate
so thing number one that I hate this is
insane so there are a couple of things
that are happening as far as college
campuses that are trying to keep me out
now
there's one college campus that is I'm
trying to remember which college campus
it is at Concordia College I'm with and
they are now trying to withdraw funding
so they funded my event there and now
they're trying to withdraw funding so
that's very exciting
that's piece of college news number one
piece of college renews number two is
that a sociology professor at the
University of California Merced told
students that he wouldn't debate me but
he would enjoy ripping my arms out of
the socket like a wookie apparently so
here's here's a little bit of the audio
that was gotten holded by Campus reform
I wouldn't because that hole is putting
this nonsense - I'd be on equal footing
with me using my real degree to
legitimize garbage policies nonsense
word means gladiator you should pass
this around while I won't debate this
fool why don't y'all set up some kind of
MMA thing between you and then the
winner can see equals forty thousand
dollars they give them to whatever
charity they want charity charity I
don't think I wouldn't enjoy rooting
this boy's shoulder out of its socket oh
my god
I don't know so he's a really real
intellectual here ripping this fools
shoulder out of his socket he sounds
like somebody who I'd have a real tough
time debating mainly because I'm not
sure that he speaks in in full sentences
what a genius he is I mean and I love
when he says he wants me to use my my
real degree to debate him dude you're a
sociology professor okay real degree I
went to Harvard Law School like shut up
it's just as absurd and this notion that
I'm gonna go and have a physical fight
with you we have this thing here it's
called civilization it's where we have
debates rights where we talk about
things but your response to an actual
civilized debate is you want to rip
somebody's arm out of their sock and
what fascist nonsense this is the second
professor I know of who suggested that
we have a fight I know everybody always
wants to have fights with me like I know
you think I'm not physically pre
possessing and you think that you can
beat me up and all this kind of nonsense
you know what I have more money than you
I can pay people to beat you up if I
wanted to I don't need to beat you up
physically plus I can defeat you
intellectually anytime I choose so of
course they revert back to their
schoolyard bully nonsense that they've
always been reverting to just just what
stupidity okay so other things that I
hate how stupid are the American people
about Star Wars I just have to ask this
because there's a poll that came out
yesterday and I have to show you the
results of this poll okay
classic this is a poll from morning
consult among 2,200 US adults on the
popularity of various figures from Star
Wars no not shockingly none of the new
Star Wars figures basically make the
list I'm shocked that June or so ends up
so low right sure so it ends up at 29%
she's one from rogue one okay how it has
jyn erso it 29% in Jar Jar Binks is at
37% Jar Jar fricken banks right fin
barely najat nudges out Jar Jar Binks
bb-8 barely nudges out Jar Jar Binks
okay that's amazing it's incredible
Emperor Palpatine by the way only
finishing at 31%
Emperor Palpatine is only at 31 like how
is that possible darth vader is only at
49%
this is percentage that is a favorable
impression of each character but I'll
tell you what the worst injustice here
is okay the worst injustice obviously is
that the people who are at the top of
the list okay lay
is number one fine you know men have a
good impression of Leia and so do women
that's cool but Luke Skywalker is number
two at 72% and Han Solo's at 68 percent
who are you people what is wrong with
you han Solo has less of a positive
percentage than Luke Skywalker I mean
even if you include the new movie Luke
Skywalker has been on an island doing
nothing staring at rocks for like 20
years
Luke Skywalker over over han Solo just
insane Luke Skywalker over obi-wan
Kenobi Luke Skywalker should be down by
like Jabba the Hutt Luke Skywalker Lando
comes in at 43%
how does Lando finish beneath beneath
c-3po or Anakin Skywalker they they
actually separated out Anakin and Darth
Vader
how does he Anakin finish above Darth
Vader how how is that a thing you'll go
to hell have you even seen these movies
so wrong with you people okay time for
the big ideas on Thursdays we talk about
a big idea that requires elucidation and
so today we will talk about freedom of
association freedom of association is
not an actual stated constitutional
right it's pretty obvious that the
Constitution means that you get to hang
out with whoever you want to hang out
with because freedom of speech and
freedom of assembly both mean freedom of
association right I get to say what I
want and the government can't control
that and I also get two so I get to
assemble for petition and assemble in
groups however I want and the Supreme
Court has found in cases like the
n-double-a-cp versus Alabama in 1958
that the n-double-a-cp did not have to
reveal to the Alabama Attorney General
the names and addresses of n-double-a-cp
members in the state because I would
violate freedom of association in 2000
the Supreme Court ruled that the Boy
Scouts could revoke the membership of a
performer Eagle Scout when it found out
that he was a gay rights activist
because they said they have freedom of
association freedom of association is
vital because it seems to me that this
should be applied to the business space
as well I get to associate with whom I
want I don't have to associate with
anybody else and I understand that there
are lots of things that people do that
are bad and of what you don't approve
and then historically speaking there
have been lots of people in the United
States who have engaged in
discriminatory practices against various
members of the population that does not
mean the government gets to for at least
the federal government does not get to
come in and force you to tailor to
audiences that you don't want or to
perform businesses with people you don't
want now this is an extreme version of
the argument
is being made in the masterpiece cake
shop case in that case they're not even
basing it on freedom of association
they're saying I have freedom of speech
you can't force me to express a message
right I'm an artist you can't force me
to express a message which is a very
strong argument I would go further I
would say you you actually should be
able to turn away people from your
business even if you just don't like
their face right you should be able to
do that
does that make you a jerk absolutely
does it make you a bad person yes should
you be able to do it yes because that is
true for every Association right if I
have a synagogue I shouldn't be forced
to admit a Christian to my synagogue and
if I have a if I have a church I
shouldn't be forced to admit a Jew right
the idea of freedom of association
requires that we all act in in society
together and then we cultivate good
people but the idea that government has
to force it down our throats I think is
a big mistake this became a big debate
during the 1964 Civil Rights Acts and
there were a lot of people making
exactly the argument I'm making Barry
Goldwater made this argument Barry
Goldwater was a civil rights activist by
the way and people proclaim that he was
racist because he said that people have
the right to choose with whom they do
business even if you don't like the
choices that they make and he was
portrayed as some sort of evil racist
for all of this there is no principled
argument for freedom of association if
the government gets to decide with whom
you associate end of story
so that's the history of freedom of
association in a nutshell it should
still apply unfortunately it's a right
that's been increasingly written out
over time we should rewrite it back into
the Constitution because if you don't
like me you shouldn't be forced to
associate with me and vice versa okay we
will be back here tomorrow with all the
latest and greatest i'm ben shapiro is
the ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alex Zangara audio is mixed by
Mike Carmina hair and makeup is by Jael
para the ben shapiro show is a daily
wire for word publishing production
copyright ford publishing 2017